aquí en heart y ve en el este de ucrania
se sigue intensificando el conflicto los
combates en las últimas horas se han
centrado en particular en el sureste de
esta ciudad entre esta ciudad de rehecho
y la ciudad división que está bajo
control ruso hemos oído diversas
explosiones también las hemos oído esta
mañana y en las últimas 24 horas ha
muerto una persona y otras tres han
resultado heridas también en un ataque
contra una industria así se encontraba
un trabajador que lamentablemente perdió
su vida o que no puede permitirse perder
esta ciudad que la segunda más
importante del país en particular
después de lo ocurrido de mariupol a una
ciudad estratégica de la shura ucraniano
que ya está bajo control ruso desde hace
varias semanas y aquí en este momento
donde nos encontramos se puede ver esta
resistencia están los paramédicos que se
juegan la vida constantemente en este
sitio y esto ocurre justamente por lo
que le comentaba antes de que los otros
no están dispuestos a perder esta ciudad
tan importante para el país